is that a musical daisy no that's a tv
show what do you mean it's not taking
dracula
a lawyer anyone no that's hey what
anybody
that would have been humiliating i can't
wait for those
gals to hear this hi i'm zachary quinto
i play harold i'm charlie carver and i
play
cowboy hey this is matt ballmer i play
donald i'm robin de asus
and i play emery i'm tuck watkins i play
hank i'm brian hutchison and i play
allen i'm michael
benjamin washington i play bernard i'm
jim parsons and i play
michael and we're in netflix's movie the
boys and the band
and now we're going to take a buzzfeed
quiz to see how many musicals we can
name
god help us
so a musical that starts with a 11.
correct
okay uh musical starts with b is babes
in toyland no
fans visit then that's big i think
that's okay the
try is it comedy barnum
carousel i i can't type that fast i'm
doing i'm on barnum
d what's d uh d is d
days and knights of molly dot no that is
that a musical days no that's a tv show
dracula is that a musical
yep it's not taking dracula what do you
mean it's not taking dracula
mystery of edwin drewed come on what's d
dreamgirl
oh yes charlie good job or you could do
dear evan hansen
trudeau um oh sh
this is getting hard already anyone no
that's a what anybody
did edward scissor sand actually make it
to broadway no this is kind of hard wait
evita oh nice
f falsettos with your man g godspell
h hairspray yeah yeah he's like i got
something i got one
i robin you got hi baby
jay there's god come on jump jeff jury
jelly jelly last jam hey
damn very good jerome is drama musical
uh
jerome robbins broadway is that going to
count you're pushing it
i know okay kiss me kate oh god that's
good
lolita no legally blonde
come on strong in the middle of the
alphabet and mamma mia which was
a michael's broadway debut
you guys this is incredible i think you
guys are incredible p
passion r uh r r
r
[Music]
oh we get a choice victor victorian hey
we about to win this y'all w with no
that's the wiz wicked thank god you got
that
that would have been humiliating x and y
u x xanadu and z zorro
zoro musical no sorba zorba we did it we
did it
okay yeah we're done i think i can't
believe we were out done
i know by them i can't wait for those
gals to hear this we love them for their
deficiencies
and their deficiencies are clear